President Trump says China could get a
better trade agreement if it helps deal
with North Korea but the u.s. is willing
to act without Beijing in a new
interview he spoke about the strength of
US Navy ships headed to the Korean
Peninsula after North Korean missile
tests we are sending an armada very
powerful
we have submarines very powerful far
more powerful than the aircraft carrier
that I can tell you and we have the best
military people on earth and I will say
this he is doing the wrong thing do you
think he's mentally fit I don't know I
don't know I don't know him but he's
doing the wrong thing analysts say North
Korea could hold another missile test
during an upcoming holiday Adriana Diaz
is in Beijing where China's president
called mr. Trump Adriana
good morning good morning China says
it's President Xi Jingping
initiated the phone call but was invited
to talk by presidents from she says
China is willing to coordinate with the
US on the North Korea issue but wants a
peaceful solution meanwhile North Korea
is preparing for a major holiday the
birthday of its founding father it would
likely feature a trademark military
parade including a defiant display of
its banned missiles on Tuesday North
Korean leader Kim jong-un addressed
Parliament but did not mention
escalating tensions with the US a u.s.
Navy Strike Group has been rerouted to
the Korean Peninsula angering Pyongyang
in a statement their foreign ministry
said it will hold the u.s. accountable
for the catastrophic consequences to be
entailed
by its outrageous actions China's
state-run tabloid warned North Korea
against any provocations the editorial
said that the u.s. is full of arrogance
after last week's missile strikes on
Syria and should not be tested Nora all
right Adrian ideas in Beijing thank you